I'm not into politics at all but this I
Biden goes I got something important I
want to say in the whole world needs to
hear it I want to show you a video of
comedian Uh Kevin Hart he was on a
podcast a couple days ago and he too has
had it with Joe Biden and I would remind
you before we play it we showed you a
clip last week of The Rock The Rock on
Joe Rogan's show saying that he's over
Joe Biden as is everybody else so
something is happening here Kevin Hart I
was watching Biden he's a clip of Biden
what Biden says and this is I probably
watched this clip I'm not into politics
at all but this I Biden goes I got
something important I want to say in the
whole world needs to hear it I need
everybody to listen right now and he
takes a beat he
goes I forget
it president of the United States so
people are realizing it right for years
literally before Joe Biden was President
I and I'm not the only one was talking
about there's something cognitively not
right with this guy we all know it the
wandering the confusion the starting of
sentences that either don't end where
they're supposed to go or just Meander
off completely like him wandering
through the the White House lawn etc etc
um between cardi B realizing that
there's a sanitation problem and blaming
that on Biden and then say Kevin Haro
and this guy's not mentally right it
does show that something thing is
happening and then what did we have what
was it about two weeks ago when David
Axelrod former Obama guy suddenly was
tweeting out oh Joe's getting kind of
old like they really are figuring it out
right now Gavin Nome hosting XI jingping
the president of China like something is
in The Ether but I mention all of this
because one of the things that the
machine does really well is no matter
how bad the Democrats are no matter how
decrepit they are or confused or
whatever is going on in their brains no
matter how bad their policies are that
lead to sanitation problems in New York
City and everything else the Democrats
always sort of stay in power at least
culturally right occasionally we get
some Republican presidents or republican
Governors or whatever but the cultural
apparatus always somehow leans
left